Traductor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
¿Estás durmiendo sin descansar,
te sientes irritable o de mal humor,
te olvidas de pequeñas cosas
y te sientes abrumado y aislado?
No te preocupes.
Todos hemos vivido eso.
Probablemente estás
simplemente estresado.
El estrés no es siempre algo malo.
Puede ser muy útil para producir
una explosión de energía y concentración
como cuando uno juega
un deporte competitivo,
o tiene que hablar en público.
Pero cuando continúa,
con lo que la mayoría
de nosotros enfrenta día a día,
esto, en realidad, empieza
a cambiar nuestro cerebro.
El estrés crónico,
como tener exceso de trabajo
o discusiones en casa,
puede afectar el tamaño del cerebro,
su estructura,
y cómo funciona,
hasta el nivel de los genes.
El estrés comienza con algo llamado
el eje hipotalámico-hipofisario-adrenal,
una serie de interacciones
entre glándulas endocrinas
en el cerebro y en el riñón,
que controla la reacción
del cuerpo al estrés.
Cuando el cerebro detecta
una situación de estrés,
su eje HHA se activa al instante
y libera cortisol, la hormona que prepara
el cuerpo para la acción inmediata.
Pero altos niveles de cortisol
durante largos períodos de tiempo
causan estragos en el cerebro.
Por ejemplo, el estrés crónico
aumenta el nivel de actividad
y el número de conexiones
neuronales en la amígdala,
centro del miedo del cerebro.
Y al aumentar los niveles de cortisol,
las señales eléctricas en el hipocampo,
la parte del cerebro asociada
al aprendizaje, los recuerdos y
el control del estrés, se deteriora.
El hipocampo también
inhibe la actividad del eje HHA,
así que cuando se debilita,
también se debilita tu capacidad
de controlar el estrés.
Sin embargo, eso no es todo.
El cortisol puede, literalmente, hacer
que tu cerebro encoja en tamaño.
Si merma demasiado implica una pérdida
de conexiones sinápticas entre neuronas
y la disminución de la corteza prefrontal,
la parte de tu cerebro que regula
conductas como la concentración,
la toma de decisiones,
el juicio,
y la interacción social.
También conduce a un menor número de
nuevas células cerebrales en el hipocampo.
Esto significa que el estrés crónico
podría dificultar que puedas aprender
y recordar cosas,
así como sentar las bases para
problemas mentales más graves,
como la depresión y, con el tiempo,
la enfermedad de Alzheimer.
Los efectos del estrés pueden filtrar
hasta el ADN de tu cerebro.
Un experimento mostró
que la cantidad de alimento que una
rata madre da a su bebé recién nacido
juega un rol determinante en cómo ese bebé
responde al estrés más tarde en la vida.
Los cachorros alimentados por las mamás
eran menos sensibles al estrés
porque sus cerebros desarrollaron
más receptores de cortisol,
que se adhieren al cortisol y
amortiguan la respuesta al estrés.
Las crías de madres negligentes
obtuvieron el resultado opuesto,
y así se volvieron más sensibles
al estrés durante toda la vida.
Estos son considerados
cambios epigenéticos,
lo que significa que afectan
cómo se expresan los genes
sin cambiar necesariamente
el código genético.
Estos cambios se pueden revertir
si se intercambian las mamás.
Pero hay un resultado sorprendente.
Los cambios epigenéticos causados
​​por una sola rata madre
se transmiten a muchas generaciones
de ratas después de ella.
En otras palabras, los resultados
de estas acciones fueron heredables.
Sin embargo, no todo son malas noticias,
Hay muchas maneras de revertir lo que
el cortisol hace en tu cerebro estresado.
Las armas más poderosas son
el ejercicio y la meditación,
que consiste en respirar profundamente
estando consciente y
centrado en tu entorno.
Ambas actividades disminuyen el estrés
y aumentan el tamaño del hipocampo,
optimizan tu memoria.
Así que no te sientas derrotado por
la presión de la vida diaria.
Obtén el control de tu estrés
antes de que él tome el control sobre ti.